that shows the true extent of human
strength a las vegas man trapped when
his car fell on top of him several
others stopped what they were doing and
jumped into action now he's coming
forward to recognize those heroic
actions that truly saved his life sasha
loftus joins us live with a story you
will only see right here on 8 news now
brian this is something you think
couldn't possibly be real but it is the
man we spoke with tonight was trapped
under this part of his car the men who
stopped and helped him were able to lift
that car completely off of him now he
just wants to say thank you
today i got lucky chance seidel
remembers the day he thought his life
might end i was right up underneath here
he was changing a tire when he slipped
underneath the car to grab a fallen lug
nut and the entire thing fell the car
came on top of me my arm was pinned
back like this across my almost to my
throat the army veteran screamed for
help and got the attention of a neighbor
who then flagged down a republic
services truck emptying trash nearby i
jumped out of the truck
and heard somebody screaming christian
flores says he and his coworker didn't
think twice
they just ran over to see what they
could do
after exhausting any other option he and
a few others lifted the car by hand so
another could pull chance out safely i
just wanted him to stay calm
let him know that everything was going
to be all right it was a feat few could
accomplish but christian says he was
just doing the right thing just doing
you know
what a human should do for another human
being as for chance he can't even begin
to describe his gratitude and he hopes
the men who saved his life
know they truly made a difference i've
been called a hero before but those guys
that day were my hero
now chance says he was stuck under that
car for about five minutes he did have a
broken collarbone and some bruised ribs
but otherwise he was just fine which
some would say is an absolute miracle
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now